moscou le soviet suprême mode la
constitution brayette et lui donne un
numéro 2 pouces nov
espagne un gouvernement de la droite au
pc pour faire face à la crise georges
marchais aux socialistes
vous faites le jeu du grand capital
giscard aux rapatriés
l'indemnisation est un pacte équitable
des rendez vous littéraire du journal
d'antenne 2 ce soir jean d'ormesson là
messieurs bonsoir une nouvelle
constitution pour l'union soviétique
nous vous l'annoncions avant-hier mais
ce qui était moins attendu c'est que
dans la foulée le soviet suprême de
l'urss donnerait au régime
un numéro 2 il s'appelle vassili kononov
jusqu alors il était fini vice ministre
des affaires étrangères depuis ce soir
il est premier vice président du
présidium ça veut dire qu'il devient
derrière lui ni brejnev le second
personnage de l'état
peut-on pour autant parler de successeur
possible
un élément de réponse il a 76 ans alors
qu'il était à nouveau question de l'état
de santé de monsieur brejnev et vous
remarquerez que le premier soviétique
s'exprime avec une légère difficulté
l'élection du premier vice-président de
l'histoire de l'urss prévu dans la
nouvelle constitution que les députés
soviétique réunissent maintenant au
kremlin viennent d'adopter cette
élection pose déjà un certain nombre de
questions
vassili kuznetsov vous allez le voir il
a 76 ans c'est un ancien négociateur de
khrouchtchev auprès des américains lors
de la crise de cuba
c'est un diplomate de haut rang mais
aussi un homme âgé dont le choix coupe
l'herbe sous les pieds de ceux qui
auraient visé ce poste comme tremplin en
cas de maladie ou de disparition du chef
de l'état c'est lui le numéro deux et
l'on comprend mieux alors le choix de ce
diplomate
surnommé l'homme des situations
difficiles tournant important va prendre
l'espagne ce week-end tous les
principaux dirigeants des partis
politiques vont se retrouver autour d'un
golf
soirée ce premier ministre pour conclure
ce que l'on appelle là-bas le pacte de
salut national et qui correspond très
grossièrement au compromis historique à
l'italienne seulement à madrid
il s'agit de s'unir face à la grave
crise économique que traverse l'espagne
aujourd'hui il semble de plus en plus
improbable que le gouvernement parvienne
à ce pacte social les syndicats plus
soucieux de renforcer leur position que
de se couper de leurs bases ne veulent
toujours pas en entendre parler
c'est sans doute dans cet esprit que le
premier ministre adolfo suarez vient de
lancer la balle dans le camp des partis
politiques de l'opposition en leur
demandant de participer avec lui demain
et après demain au palais de la moncloa
à une sorte de sommet politique qui
devrait déboucher sur une espèce de
compromis à mi chemin entre les
avantages que peut présenter un
gouvernement de coalition et la promesse
d'une neutralité parlementaire de ce
sommet politique
adolfo suarez peut sortir dimanche soir
comme l'homme le mieux armé pour lutter
contre la crise qui menace le plus
l'espagne la crise économique
il peut en sortir également avec un
blason un peu redoré à la suite des
nombreuses hésitations qui ont
caractérisé la politique gouvernementale
depuis les élections du 15 juin dernier
et hier soir c'est un demi million de
personnes malgré la pluie qui ont défilé
pacifiquement pour protester contre la
vie chère en espagne sachez que
l'inflation pour 77 va frôler les 30 %
une manifestation précédée la veille par
un autre meeting organisé par les
principales centrales syndicales et qui
traduit bien je crois
l'importance de la crise
plus de deux cent cinquante mille
personnes dans les rues de madrid
scandant des slogans contre la vie chère
c'est l'épreuve majeure à laquelle doit
faire face le gouvernement soares le
premier ministre espagnol a gagné la
bataille de la démocratie au 15 juin
dernier il doit à présent conquérir sa
crédibilité sur le terrain économique
l'espagne est chaque jour un peu plus
cher la facture de la dictature
la hausse des prix prévue pour 1977 est
de l'ordre de 30%
elle frappe de plein fouet les ménages
elle fait aussi des ravages à la bourse
qui bat ses records à la baisse
jamais depuis plus de trente ans les
cours n'avaient été aussi bas l
investisseur ne savent pas en réalité
quelle attitude prendre face à la crise
économique et à la crise politique qui
s'entremêlent il n'y a aucun indice
précis pour le monde boursier qui n'est
pas habitué à la nouvelle situation dans
laquelle se trouve l'espagne on parle
aussi beaucoup d'impact social
nous sommes actuellement en train
d'essayer d'arriver à cet accord c'est
très difficile parce que nous inaugurons
la démocratie cela dénature un peu le
contenu économique des choses
chacun voit midi à sa porte et il est
difficile dans ces conditions d'arriver
à un accord mais je crois que c'est la
seule solution
un pacte social pour combattre
l'inflation en ralentissant la bourse
prix salaires c'est l'idée des
économistes du gouvernement
il faudrait pour y parvenir signé un
accord les grandes centrales s'ils
refusent tant que ne sont pas rétablis
les libertés syndicales dans les
entreprises et il y a
le syndicat au moins lui jeter va
demander toujours aux travailleurs de
défendre ses intérêts ne pouvons pas
supporter d'être le seul à payer
les prix de la crise nous avons plein
conscience de la nécessité d'arriver à
de nouvelles situations qui provoque
moins de conflits mais nous savons pas
faire des pompiers de la situation
sociale pour gagner les syndiqués à sa
cause
adolfo suarez promet des élections
syndicales avant le 15 novembre et pour
que les prochaines élections municipales
qui doivent savoir
la fin de l'année ne soit pas un échec
le premier ministre doit aussi obtenir
des résultats rapides et surtout un
large soutien à sa politique économique
sans pacte social bitton en espagne le
gouvernement sera en difficulté
c'est vrai et ce pourrait aussi être le
cas de la nouvelle démocratie espagnole
dans le parlement commence tout juste à
rédiger la constitution
et enfin il faut savoir qu'une nouvelle
amnistie est en vue en espagne elle
touchera pratiquement tous les
prisonniers politiques y compris donc
les basques à faire carlos deux ans
après la fusillade de la rue toullier à
paris la cour de sûreté de l'état se
déclare incompétente
enfin un entretien ce matin entre le
premier ministre israélien et jacques
chaban-delmas 1h40 entre les deux hommes
à l'hôpital où se reposent monsieur
begin la politique c'est maintenant à
une double attaque que doit faire face
françois mitterrand revenus du congrès
travailliste de brown attaques de
raymond barre qui hier sur tf1 le
qualifié de prince de l'équivoque
attaques renouvelées aujourd'hui de
georges marchais qui estime que le ps
prend ses distances avec l'union de la
gauche et qu'ils renforcent ainsi chez
le tenant du pouvoir actuel du site
l'espoir de sauvegarder la politique du
grand capital alors questions des
journalistes tout à l'heure à l'occasion
de la conférence de presse voilà quand
même une curieuse convergence d'attac
réponse de georges marchais écoutons là
je pense j'ai bien le lien tout à
l'heure qu'il est bien regrettable que
de parti socialiste par son comportement
par sunu menant à droite par son refus
d' actualiser le programme commun par
l'abandon des dispositions essentielles
contenues dans le programme de 1972
efforts ni à monsieur bart et à la
majorité la possibilité d'utiliser une
situation dans laquelle le parti
communiste français ne porte aucune
responsabilité bien devant cette
avalanche de critiques françois
mitterrand aura quand même pu enregister
aujourd'hui le soutien mesuré d'edmond
maire qui souhaite néanmoins au nom de
la cfdt avoir plus de précisions sur les
projets économiques et sociaux du leader
socialiste
il s'agit là d'une polémique entre
partis est vraiment ce n'est pas le rôle
de la cfdt de rentrer dans ce genre de
débat partisan mais est ce que la crise
a créé au sein de la gauche vous à
rapprocher du parti socialiste la crise
de la gauche a amené la cfdt à avoir une
expression très net sur la politique de
chacun des deux parties est ce que nous
avons à dire à chacun des deux est de
nature différente au parti communiste
nous disant que nous sommes en désaccord
total avec sa stratégie car ils situent
toutes ces solutions dans un cadre
national alors que la france exporte 40%
de sa production et du même coup il fait
courir le risque d'une nationalisme
économique d'une fermeture des
frontières ce qui veut dire à terme la
baisse du niveau de vie et les tensions
internationales
nous on est donc davantage proche du
parti socialiste actuellement l'analyse
du parti socialiste qui situe la crise
française dans son contexte
international nous semble plus réel mais
le problème vis-à-vis du parti
socialiste c'est qu'il y ait un décalage
très important entre ces orientations
déclaré autogestionnaire et la réalité
de ces propositions parti socialiste met
fortement l'accent sur les difficultés à
résoudre la reflation les contraintes
économiques internationales
mais ces propositions ne nous semble pas
suffisante pour donner confiance dans sa
volonté de mettre en cause les
mécanismes de la domination capitaliste
nationale et internationale nous
souhaitons donc que le parti socialiste
affirment ces propositions et montre
crête clairement sa volonté de
changement voilà nous voilà au terme
d'une semaine encore politiquement
chargé je crois qu'il faut s'arrêter un
petit peu essayé de faire le point alain
duhamel
d'abord pourquoi raymond barre et
apparemment derrière lui toute la
majorité giscardienne attaque si vite et
si dure françois mitterrand pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord pour des
raisons tactiques françois mitterrand
est en difficulté puisqu'il est déjà
attaqué par son principal partenaire le
pc donc raymond barre en profite c'est
normal ensuite sans doute pour une
raison psychologique parce que comme
vous le savez les alliés de raymond
barre en particulier lui et repères sont
quelquefois un petit peu inquiet des
relations entre le premier ministre le
président de la république et les
socialistes à leurs rangs les attaquants
comme ça y'a pas de problème on montre
bien que de ce côté là il n'y a rien à
craindre pour eux pour puis il ya une
raison de fond c'est que le parti
socialiste et le principal adverse
pour la majorité parce que c'est le
parti socialiste qui a gagné des voix
ces dernières années ces voix il les a
prises en fait à des gens qui pourraient
voter pour la majorité donc c'est lui
qu'il faut attaquer alors puisqu'on
parle vraiment bar est ce qu'on peut
considérer que politiquement il est
entré en lice oui et non il est entrée
en lice dans la mesure où il a attaqué
dur il a montré qu'ils savent attaquer
dur principalement françois mitterrand
accessoirement un petit peu par des
petites coupes pâte discret d'ailleurs
jacques chirac dont il a montré qu'ils
savaient faire des bons mots il a
rappelé qu'ils ne se trompait pas
forcément dans ses analyses politiques
en plus ils détestent qu'on dise que
c'est ta débute en politique comme vous
le savez donc de ce point de vue oui il
a attaqué et oui donc c'est la politique
en même temps il faut se méfier dans la
mesure où il n'a pas tout dit cuir lui
aussi a maintenu une certaine stratégie
du brouillard s'agissant de ses
intentions et notamment du point de
savoir s'il donnerait ou non des
investitures pour les pour les
prochaines élections
bon et puis comme le président la
république qui fait aussi délibérément
un petit peu une course de lenteur dire
que manifestement il pense qu'il faudra
démarrer tard en décembre peut-être
voire même en janvier en ce qui le
concerne
parlons maintenant du pilonnage du parti
communiste contre françois mitterrand
raconte le parti socialiste ça va durer
combien de temps et quelle hypothèse on
peut formuler ce qui est sûr c'est que
ça ne va pas s'arrêter rapidement je
veux dire que à partir du montant à
partir du moment où le parti communiste
a décidé par exemple de repousser sa
conférence nationale qui devait avoir
lieu ce mois ci et qui probablement
n'aura pas lieu avant le début de
l'année prochaine ça signifie que
automatiquement le pilonnage continuera
jusqu'à ce moment là maintenant la
question qui se pose c'est de savoir si
s'arrêtera ou non avant les élections c
est ce qu y aura ou non un accord
électoral que l'or il ya trois
hypothèses en fait je voulais qu'ils
continuent à exister lune ce qui est pas
d'accord du tout bon ça n'est pas
l'hypothèse la plus probable mais on
peut pas l'exclure et georges marchais
ce ne prends pas d'engagement sur ce
point bon la seconde qui un simple
accord électoral de désistement si vous
voulez et puis la troisième c'est que in
extremis y est un accord d'actualisation
du programme commun si c'est la première
solution
le pilonnage continuera jusqu'au bout si
c'est la deuxième ou la troisième île
sans être un peu avant voir nous sommes
à la veille
directeur du parti socialiste ce
pilonnage de françois mitterrand sur
france inter de gauche et de droite
est ce que c'est si mauvais que ça pour
y écouter je dirais semblera être
normand je dirais que le fait qu un
pilonnage contre lui des deux côtés et
mauvais puisqu'il est naturellement la
cible principale
il arrive à incarner l'unité et tayrac
donc que c'est beaucoup plus difficile
en même temps je l'aide d'une certaine
façon les les deux pilonnage se tirent
sur eux mêmes parce que quand raymond
barre attaque françois mitterrand du
coup c'est difficile que georges
marchais soit pris au pied de la lettre
quand il dit qu'il prend un tournant de
même symétriquement quand raymond barre
attaque françois mitterrand cause du
programme commun on se dit oui mais
georges marchais la tête de son côté
alors je dirais que en fait pour le
parti socialiste
beaucoup dépendra de sa capacité à
maintenir sa propre unité et ça c'est
sans doute ce qu'on vend ce week end le
reste de la politique en bref première
journée du congrès extraordinaire du cds
a lyon les 12 cents délégués ont reçu un
petit livre bleu de 250 pages chez la
plateforme b centriste andré diligent a
demandé l'instauration de la
proportionnelle
avant les législatives la loi sur le
crédit à la consommation dont nous vous
parlions hier a été voté sans grand
changement à l'assemblée un petit
événement quand même a été votée à
l'unanimité tous groupes politiques
confondus
enfin à les rapatrier chez valéry
giscard d'estaing a déjeuné cet
après-midi le pré république a qualifié
l'indemnisation des rapatriés de pacte
équitable le projet de loi du
gouvernement reconnaîtra d'abord le
droit des rapatriés à l'indemnisation le
plafond qui sera choisi permettra de
régler plus de 95% des dossiers un
complément d'indemnisation sera remis en
1978 sous forme de titres ayant une
valeur financière et portant un intérêt
analogue à celui de la caisse d'epargne
le remboursement de ses titres se fera à
partir de 1979 en commençant par les
bénéficiaires les plus âgés au total le
projet de loi proposera 2 x 3 l'effort
financier en faveur des rapatriés
voilà les orientations définies sans le
président de réé reste étanche
certaines précisions que nous comprenons
car il devra encore divulgué ce qui va
être décidé
on chante conseil mais ce qui nous a dit
à certains égards encourageant je lance
départ et jo je ne voudrais pas en dire
davantage
parce qu'il n'a pas pu encore nous
donner précision ni sur le plafonnement
et sur certaines modalités de ce qui est
envisagé mais bon je dois aller près
préparé par le gouvernement
il semble et parmi les dix rapatrier le
président des rapatriés de confession
islamique
le chef de l'etat sera dimanche à lyon
pour une journée des personnes âgées à
l'occasion de laquelle il réunira près
de 5000 de ce qu'on appelle le troisième
âge nous avons préféré antenne 2 le
qualificatif de nouvelles vagues ce sera
le titre de samedi et demi l'émission de
jean-pierre elkabbach demain avec de
nombreux témoignages et invités demain
donc à 12h30 une émission sur les
problèmes des personnes âgées une
catastrophe évitée par miracle un
mont-de-marsan un mirage iv s'est écrasé
sur une caserne de gendarmes mobiles
personne n'était dans les appartements
lorsque l'accident s'est produit un peu
avant midi malheureusement le pilote et
le navigateur n'ont pu faire fonctionner
leur siège éjectable
tous deux ont péri dans l'accident
flottera fera pas c'est la question que
l'on se posait ces derniers jours à
propos de ces fameux iceberg dans
l'antarctique que certains avaient
projeté de remorquer jusqu'en arabie
saoudite et bien finalement le projet
n'a pas fondu comme neige au soleil
il ne sera simplement plus français
cela fait dix ans que cet iceberg repéré
par les photos des satellites américains
tournent grâce aux courants autour de
l'antarctique
c'est énorme à xpert d'eau douce fait 74
km de long et 41 km de large
le type même de ce qu'une équipe
française sous été remorqué jusqu en
arabie séoudite pour y amener de l'eau
douce
ne l'oublions pas 97 % de l'eau douce se
trouve au pôle sud sous forme de glace
alors pourquoi ne pas essayer de
l'utiliser pour les régions arides ou
désertiques
malheureusement la société française
cicero promotrice de l'idée a fait
faillite
le projet n'est pourtant pas abandonné
et ce sera sûrement les américains qui
le réaliseront avec l'arabie ces outils
et cette eau-là coûtera deux fois moins
chère que celle produite par une usine
de dessalement certains écologistes sont
inquiet des répercussions possibles
d'une telle opération mais à l'échelle
d'un océan un iceberg
ce n'est même pas un glaçon et ce n'est
pas demain que la masse polaire
diminuera les réserves sont énormes et
de toute façon le premier essai n'a pas
encore commencé le sport maintenant avec
d'abord un coup de chapeau pour les
judokas français qui ont surclassé les
japonais au stade pierre de coubertin à
paris
un exemple jean luc rougé a mis 14
secondes pour envoyer son adversaire de
110 kg à terre football on connaît
maintenant la composition de l'équipe de
france qui doit affronter l'urss demain
soir au parc des princes
à noter l'arrivée du monégasque petit et
puis une petite polémique entre le
patron de l'équipe de france qui
s'entraînent ici au touquet michel
hidalgo et roger rocher le président des
verts qui trouvent que l'on fait un
petit peu trop appel à ses joueurs ont
les épuise réponse de michel hidalgo
dans france soir
si on ne veut plus de l'équipe de france
de football on dit le tennis ce sont
toujours les anciens qui tiennent le
haut du pavé dans le national à
strasbourg
qualifié pour les demi-finales geoffrey
proisy dominguez et puis un jeune espoir
quand même l'alsacien fraysse enfin la
voile car je trouve que nous avons été
trop discret faute d'image bien sûr sur
ce magnifique tour du monde à la voile
cette voile rouge et verte que oui à
part être derrière moi c'est celle du
hollandais fly vainqueur de la première
manche au cap devant l'anglais king's
legends de deux petites heures seulement
pendant de longs jours
les deux bateaux étaient bord à bord
great britain tout le plus grand bateau
termine troisième les français gauloise
et neptune sont attendus ce week end
et puis comme chaque vendredi avant
apostrophe à 21h50 une couleur disons
plus littéraire d'un journal avec les
choix d'un grand écrivain
aujourd'hui jean d'ormesson qui nous
parle d'un des ouvrages les plus
importants de la rentrée
le dernier livre de marguerite yourcenar
marguerite yourcenar vous donne le
deuxième tome de son autobiographie
les lecteurs se souviennent peut-être du
premier tome qui s'appelait souvenirs
pieux voici le second qui s'appelle
archives du nord le propre de cette ce
viagra fils et que l'auteur y parle très
peu le soi même dans souvenirs pieux
marguerite yourcenar partait du jour de
sa naissance et remontait le temps
évoquant successivement sa mère sa
grand-mère et ses dents archives du nord
marguerite yourcenar suit le chemin
inverse
elle descend le temps et elle commence
assez loin puisque elle commence à la
préhistoire voyons ensuite la conquête
de la gaule par jules césar
la flandre au moyen-âge les flandres
françaises
le xviie et xviiie siècles et puis comme
à la télévision la caméra sert de plus
en plus ses personnages et nous voyons
en gros plan le grand père et le père
marguerite yourcenar personnage
admirable qui se situe à mi-chemin des
souvenirs de l'histoire et du ram
c'est un grand livre jean d'ormesson ce
que vous ne pensez pas que ce livre là
et puis tous les autres de mariétou
sonar lui permettrait d'être là la
preuve
la femme académiciens je vais répondre à
titre strictement personnel je souhaite
très vivement que marguerite yourcenar
entre à l'académie française je crois
que malgré du renard est un des plus
grands écrivains français vivant
naturellement il ya les obstacles
marc vécurent senard n'habite pas la
france à la [ __ ] des états unis et puis
c'est une femme et jusqu'à présent
l'académie française n'a pas accueilli
de femmes
mais justement il me semble que le
moment est venu d'accueillir une femme
et je crois que personne n'est plus
digne d'entrer à l'académie comme arthur
sonar et je crois que l'académie
française s'honorerait en accueillant
l'auteur de des mémoires d'hadrien de
l'oeuvre noir et des nouvelles
orientales en tout cas je pense que la
ferme ne dépend que de marguerite
yourcenar
elle met alors on verra j'ai eu le temps
avant de nous dire au revoir devoir
affronter cette belle histoire qui nous
vient d'en donner c'est l'histoire d'un
monsieur qui n'est plus tout jeune il à
117 ans
comme il n'avait toujours pas obtenu
d'enfants d'aucune de ces 17 précédente
femme monsieur omar c'est son nom s'est
choisi une cadrage nerfs mais manque de
chance elle était divorcée
le couple a dans le vécu d'un
concubinage ce qui n'est pas permis là
bas ils autorités ont envoyé la dame en
prison alors l'alertent vieillard a tout
vendu ce qu'ils avaient pour sortir de
prison
l'élue de son coeur avec l'espoir sa
virilité et dans d'avoir enfin à 117 ans
un premier rocheteau c'est tout à fait
vrai cette histoire le temps pour
terminer il sera très nuageuse demain
des vosges à la corse donc sur l'extrême
est sur toutes les autres régions
alternance de nuages et d'éclaircies
local des températures baisseront un peu
dans l'est et pour dimanche et bien même
type de temps avec en plus des pluies
dans le sud-ouest
voilà c'était l'actualité du vendredi 7
octobre dernier rendez vous avec le
journal vers 22h45 avec gérard holtz
bonsoir à tous
à lundi